you're about to watch one of my brand
new segments spot the fake headline that
I do live every single week exclusively
in my member block on daily wire plus my
Show's member block is unique each day
and includes music video reviews
exclusive interviews woke commercials
and all those extra stories while I hear
directly from you live in the daily wire
chat click the link in the description
below so you don't miss out it is like a
whole other YouTube channel
away from all the sensors just for you
headline Burger King Austria now asks
customers regular or with meat
so this is for sure real I totally
believe this it's ridiculous that you go
to Burger King you go and they say Okay
I want to have a hamburger give me a
Whopper hamburger and they say okay do
you want a hamburger with meat
or not with me obviously it should have
me but I believe
this is a real
headline next one oh this meet a
Canadian man who's sharing his vasectomy
experience to encourage men there and in
the U.S post Roe v Wade this is from
Insider which is a very liberal Outlet
Olivier chabano a 28 year old man from
Canada got a vasectomy in November and I
hate to point it out but he put the
picture out there this guy looks like
the kind of guy who at the age of 28
would get it this guy looks like the
kind of guy who says I will never
ever want any children I just want
promiscuous sex and no responsibility
whatsoever he looks like a male feminist
the feminists are not sending their best
when it comes to men he says you are not
dancing Tango alone so we have to share
the responsibility if we want to keep
having promiscuous sex with these women
without any accountability without
having to take care of them by golly we
got to get sniffed this is The Logical
conclusion of feminism by the way
gelding the men very sad don't do it
feminism fellas not even once not even
once right now head on over to
expressvpn.com Michael YT let me ask you
something what if there were someone out
there who kept a log of every single
thing you did every minute of the day
that would be pretty creepy right well
what if I told you that happens that is
exactly what happens every time you go
online your internet provider such as at
T or comcast is allowed to store logs of
every website you've ever visited and
can legally sell those data to anyone
that's why I use expressvpn expressvpn
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure servers
so that your internet provider cannot
see your log what you do online now many
of you might be wondering well if I'm
routing all my data through a VPN then
doesn't that just mean the VPN can see
what I'm doing and log my dad instead
good question you're right to think that
expressvpn though is the only VPN that I
trust because they use trusted server
technology they were the first major VPN
provider to engineer all of their VPN
servers to run in Ram this makes it
impossible for their VPN servers to
store any data including logs of any
expressvpn customer you don't need to
take my word for it or expressvpn's word
for it expressvpn is so confident of
their no logs claim that they even had
one of the biggest Assurance firms
pricewaterhousecooper audit their
technology stop letting people keep logs
of what you do online visit
expressvpn.com Michael YT right now find
out how you can get three months for
free next one Scotland cut down 14
million trees to clear the way for wind
turbines okay I don't know if I believe
this one light last year Scotland was
the site of the un's 26th Conference of
the parties the cop 26 climate Summit
the globalists agreed to end
deforestation by 2030
so the slaughter of 14 million trees
would seem an ironic move but indeed
that's what Scotland did I don't know
that I believe this I'm going to put
this to the side right now see what the
other ones are NDP MP suggests ice
hockey should be played without ice to
stop climate change
is indoor skating ice even a necessity
anymore can every ice sport be done
without ice and different equipment can
you do this is what the libs do all the
time A friend of mine in a way he's like
a right-wing communist or a radical left
conservative he's got very idiosyncratic
political views but he's right about a
lot of things and he pointed out to me
years ago one marker of the libs is they
always want the appearance of the thing
but without the essence of that thing
they're the sort of people who drink
decaf coffee they want sex without the
natural conclusion of sex they want
the appearance of femininity without
actually being a woman
and here you the people want the libs
want ice hockey without the ice
it's not possible to do I'm gonna also
put this I don't know if that's real and
then finally
uh
deadline Boston Children's Hospital
throws child off roof after she claims
to be a bird
okay I think not even the crazy Libs at
Boston Children's Hospital
which has a pediatric transgender Clinic
I don't think that even they would throw
a baby off throw a kid off the roof
uh because the kid says that he's a bird
uh this has got to be what Babylon b or
something like that so okay very funny
great headline that means the ice hockey
thing is legit but then this one this
one really got me what's the rest of the
story Herald authorities in Scotland
approve the removal of 14 million trees
to clear Forest land for 21 wind
turbines wow
it's like that episode of South Park
where the kids go out hunting with
stands uncle uncle Jimbo who's a
right-wing crazy Hunter and he says you
know a part of hunting is conserving the
species and he's got all these crazy
guns and he obviously just loves blowing
up animals he goes and so what we have
to do to conserve the species because
they overpopulate us we have to kill
them we have to kill the deer or else
they will die
and the kids look at him and say ah that
doesn't and actually there there is an
argument here when we're talking about
uh tending to a flock of animals
that you have to kind of trim the flock
a little bit
for the health overall of them I don't
think that that would apply to
14 million trees so that you can build
21 absolutely terrible
wind turbines
ugly hideous they pretend that this is
good for the environment really really
bizarre sad stuff folks I hope you were
able to spot the fake headline if you
want to join to watch me guess live and
weeks before anyone else click the link
in the description and join the Michael
Knowles show member block to get that
and so much more on daily wire plus see
you there
[Music]
[Music]